Conditional probability is
an absolutely basic idea
that we use all the time.
It's the probability
that some event occurs,
given certain
information about it.
For example, an
insurance company
wants to know, what's the
probability that you'll
live for the next 10 years
given your medical history?
Or a typical investor
wants to know,
what's the probability that
this stock is going to rise
given its stock price
gyrations for the past month?
There are people who
actually think you
could do that, the chartists.
That, not knowing anything
about the nature of the company,
or the business that
the stock is part of,
that just by watching the price
gyration you can make a better
guess on what the
stock will do tomorrow
than you could otherwise.
Another good example is
for a system engineer.
What's the probability that the
system is going to overload,
given the recent history of
the rate at which requests
have been coming in?
And finally, as a joke
that I like to think about,
is, what's the
probability that you're
a cat owner, given
that you're sitting
in the cat section of the Angell
Memorial Veterinary Hospital?
OK.
So let's look concretely
at a very simple example
of conditional
probability that's
meant to be illustrative,
where we look at a die,
and rolling a fair die.
OK.
Now if I'm thinking about
an ordinary fair die,
I've got 6 outcomes
that are equally likely.
The outcomes are one, two,
three, four, five, six.
And if I ask, what's the
probability that in one roll,
I roll a one?
Well it's going to be the
number of outcomes involving
my rolling a one, divided by
the total number of outcomes.
It's one-sixth.
The probability of any given
face of a six-sided fair die
is one-sixth.
But suppose I give you some
additional information.
Knowledge about
the roll can change
the judgment of probabilities.
Suppose that I tell you
that I rolled an odd number.
And now I want to know
what's the probability that I
rolled a one?
And the answer will now be that,
given that it's an odd number,
the only possibilities
are one, three, and five.
And so the probability
has changed to one-third.
That should be a
straightforward enough idea.
One way to understand
conditional probability
is as a kind of
experiment, where first you
try to roll an odd
number and then you
do you decide what final
roll you're going to make.
Let's look at that tree, if we
were describing it that way.
So the first branch
of the tree that we'll
use to build a
probability space is
to say, OK, among the six
possible outcomes, what
are the chances that we
rolled an odd number?
Well, it's 50/50, because
there are three of each.
So there's one-half chance that
yes, you rolled an odd number.
In which case those are
the possible outcomes.
Or a one-half chance that no,
you didn't roll an odd number,
and the possible outcomes
then are two, four, and six.
Now, once you're here
with one, three, and five,
let's ask whether
you rolled a one.
The probability that
you did roll a one,
we've already
agreed is one-third.
It's equally likely to be any
one of those three outcomes.
Which means that it's two-thirds
that you wind up rolling
either a three or a five.
And likewise, here,
the probability
if you didn't roll
an odd number, that
is, you rolled an even number,
the probability that next
you'll roll a one is zero.
Or that you won't roll a
one is probability one.
So this is a kind
of standard way
that we have of trying to
build up a set of probabilities
for outcomes.
And if we look at this
tree, well, first of all,
we can use it to assign
some probabilities.
Because the probability
of your rolling
a one is one-sixth,
as it should be.
It's one-half times
one-third, which
is the usual way we would
calculate the probability
of this outcome.
By the way, we could calculate
the probability of the outcome
being three or five.
It would be one-half times
two-thirds or one-third.
And finally, the probability
of rolling an even number
would just be one-half.
One-half times one.
Now, what's going on here?
Well, if you look at
this number, one-third,
it is what we said was
the probability of a one,
given that you
rolled an odd number.
So that's where this
label came from.
Likewise, this
number, two-thirds,
is the probability that you
didn't roll a one, given
that you rolled an odd number.
And finally, this number
is the probability
that you didn't
roll a one, given
that you rolled an even number.
And it's certain.
Let's do another example
to get this idea across.
Let's go back to Monty Hall,
which we've seen before.
Remember how we
have the probability
labels on these branches,
which we figured out.
So if we look at this number,
one-third, what is it?
Well this is where the
prize is at Location One
and the contestant
has picked Door One.
And that one-third,
we figured out
that once the prize
is at Door One,
in fact, wherever the
prize is, the probability
that the contestant will
pick One is one-third.
This number, one-third,
is the probability
the contestant
will pick One given
that the prize is at Door One.
Yeah?
Here's another third.
This is, similarly, the
probability that the contestant
will pick Door Two given that
the prize is at Door Three.
It's symmetric to this one.
But here's something a
little bit different.
Here's one-half.
This is the probability
that Door Three
will be opened by Carol
given that the prize is
at One-- that's that branch--
and the contestant picked One.
And when the prize is at One
and the contestant picks One,
Carol, we said in our
model, is equally likely
to open the two possible
doors that have goats
that she's able to open.
And so that's one-half, is
this conditional probability.
The probability that
she'll open Door Three
given that we're in this
location in the tree.
Given that the prize is
at One and pick is at One.
So the point is simply
that we were reasoning
about conditional probability in
the very way we began defining
the tree model that we were
using to define probability
spaces in the first place.
We were implicitly using
conditional probabilities
to label the probabilities that
left each vertex of the tree.
And in fact, formally
speaking, what we were using
was the product rule.
Which is that, the probability
that an A event occurs and a B
event occurs is
simply the probability
that the A event-- that's the
first branch of the tree--
times the probability
of B given A. That's
the fundamental rule of
conditional probabilities.
That's the product rule, and
it's something to be memorized.
In fact, this product
rule is not a corollary.
It's really the definition
of conditional probability.
So all of the
previous discussion
was motivation of the
following definition.
If A and B are events
in a probability space,
the probability
of B, given A, is
defined to be the probability
that A and B occur--
that is, A intersection B--
relative to the probability
of A.
So that's the formal definition.
So this formal definition
justifies the product rule
by definition.
Because you just multiply both
sides by the probability of A.
And you get probability of A
times the probability of B,
given A is the probability
of the intersection.
Notice that implicit
in this definition
is, the probability of
A better not be zero.
So you can't
condition on an event
that has zero probability.
Probability of B given A is
only defined if probability of A
is positive.
OK.
If you have a tree
that's of depth three,
then you need a product rule
for three consecutive choices.
And it generalizes in
a straightforward way.
Namely, the probability of A and
B and C-- the first branch is A
and the second branch is
B and the third branch
is C-- is the probability that
you do A on the first branch,
times the probability
that you do
B on the second branch,
given that you did
A on the first branch,
and times the probability
that you do C on
the third branch,
given that you did A on the
first and B on the second.
And this product rule
for three could, in fact,
be proved simply by
substitution, using the product
rule for two twice.
And of course it generalizes
to any finite number of sets.
Another useful way to
think about probability,
that may be a more intuitive
than the idea of choosing
to whether or not to roll
odd and then choosing
whether or not to roll a one,
usually what you think of is,
you rolled the dice
and then you're
giving me some information
about what that roll was.
I don't think about the
odds of rolling odd or not.
I just tell you
it's odd, and now
tell me what is the probability
that, among those odd outcomes,
it was one.
So a way to formalize
that is, you
could think of
conditioning on an event A
as defining a new probability
function on the sample space.
Once you're given
that A occurred,
I can now think that all the
probabilities of the sample
of the outcomes have changed.
So I'll define a new
probability measure
relative to A, where all the
outcomes that are not in A
are going to be assigned
probability zero.
Because they can't happen
given that A occurred.
And all of the probabilities
of outcomes of points in A,
they get their probability
raised in proportion to A.
Because now A is going to
be whole probability space.
Let's be a little bit
more formal about that,
to be precise.
We're going to define a
new probability function.
Probability sub A, on
the same sample space,
where the probability
of an outcome
is zero if the
outcome is not in A,
and its old probability
relativized to the probability
of A, if omega is in A.
So that's the definition
of the probability
with respect to A of omega.
It's a new probability measure
on the same sample space.
So to verify that this new
thing is a probability space,
you have to verify that the sum
of the outcome probabilities
is one.
And that's a little
exercise that I
would encourage you to stop now
and work out a piece of paper.
Because it's trivial,
but it's worth
checking that you
follow the definitions.
The claim is simply that
this new measure, probability
sub A--
[NO SOUND]
--will satisfy all of
the rules of probability.
Because it is a
probability measure.
So for example, I have the
difference rule restated
for conditional probabilities.
Given that probability sub
A is a probability measure,
it satisfies the
difference rule.
Which means when I translate it
into a conditional probability
statement, I get that the
probability of B minus C,
given A, is equal to
the probability of B,
given A, minus the probability
of B intersection C, given A.
It's exactly the same as the
standard difference rule,
except that I have it made
everything conditioned on A.
And so we automatically
get all of these rules
for conditional probability that
we had holding for probability.
Which will be helpful.
We won't have to think
about proving them again.